[Music]
the first drive is the straight wall
ride the second act is our go-kart but
four wheels this time
so that it's right in one of these
lovely ladies and when you do hands off
stand it up hands off sitting on the
sides standing on the side and a whole
array of Acts it's an experience you
can't prepare anything remotely I'm
Terry Cameron and iron wall of death
Rider and I ride for Luke Fox's original
wall of death these are our wildest
races after we take your way back inside
this is when I think when I started
writing the wall of death by pure
accident I used to work with horses and
fortunately where I was working in the
place shut down
so naturally we went the job centre and
I just typed in horse rider into the
search engine and Willard s rider came
up and we're down to the art and they
had the wall built up I knew there and
then that was it
you do you're very good universe that's
right you got building somewhere up to
the dizziness you have to go at least
first in all our sale on with otherwise
gravity which is whip you stray off it's
a mixture free thing so balance speed
and I'll see their stamina lifting your
arm up so we're good by Theo is quite a
feat is a good feeling being a female
rider in this Latin environment
it gives me a great buzz a lot of people
when they see you walk into the wall we
can see here a bit of flash you know but
as soon as they see you get on the bike
you can hear like murmur stay home
there's a girl on motorbike see all
their faces like up and then after the
so all the girls they're like wow you've
got bigger balls and most of them but
but it's great to know that they look
really thinking bull if you can do it
then okay
[Music]
I'm skating with these women I feel on
fire I love roller skating so much that
I decided that I was going to bring it
back for everyone
[Music]
I'm a South Island better known as
estrogen and I'm the founder of moxie
roller skates there are 21 skaters on
the masti speaking worldwide but some of
them are pigeon indeed Imogen
smelly and with legs anything that's
experimental or outside of what you've
probably seen on roller skates is what
we do roller skating was really really
big until I was born and then it really
kind of dropped off when rollerblades
came in roller skate innovation just
stopped
roller derby was the next new sport to
come to the roller skating industry this
piece that they were selling the roller
derby skaters were made for speed this
case that we're making now are made for
secure landing for high-flying tricks
you know a few years ago there works
like scowl stealing backflips and on the
on wheel and now there are and I'm
amazed at what my body can do I really
am we are chasing our dreams we're
chasing that feeling that wonderful
floaty feeling of being alive and you
will get that firm Rollerson it's this
strange new feeling the freak rushing
off this dress
[Music]
todo mundo sabe que no te puede guitar
la vida pero Yo no Pinto silly okay so
todo contrary my el Torro milada nombre
es o su mano Elena sweater fotos de tous
el récord a es la fuerza de ponente
entre en de la cara de toro y rats del
sing in potato la diferencia entre entre
el mundo del record a la storia de todos
passe à la vista Sano nosotros
salimos an frente knows a los toros
cinnamon chip Oh de dooda Nimule eaten
es pas de nada Tom Povich in Visalia CA
ninguna al Toro
es una lucha dough into a tube en el
mundo de Dell record a system tasty
polish Huertas laaser LTS a pun to
endure serra da y bueno los voices de
[ __ ] Caleb invasion CL port a all-star
todo el quiero es bueno pues la
paciencia llamas alta para me non-nil
Oviedo como en amigo yo como amigos
yo desde que no tiene siempre de nuit
token Adomian gusta mucho los todos Yan
persico's kanojo Nova Diez años de la
capilla de de de de mi pollo dari below
combogia Chiquitita kita
yo-dee-hey cuando en este mundo que
cuando padre de área de sade Rico tar
pero hace nada sido Padre Cho in Capades
hallo yo la verdad que cuando su Devante
de la cara de los todos lo único que
siento soon Alegria in Mensa la
felicidad que make reduce a star delante
la cara de este año animal cuando yo
momento dare venti doll co dejar a
strobe ova nunca
Elkanah circuited or a de condado de se
hace a hand oh like a skater has a
skateboarder BMXer has a bike I just saw
the whale turns off his fun so why not
take it into the park
[Music]
I'm Erin wheels bothering him and I ride
WCMS WCM X stands for wheelchair
motocross it's you know taking your
chair into the skate park and hitting
ramp kind of the same thing as BMX but
with a wheelchair I first started going
to the skate park when I was 8 years old
and I've been doing it for 16 years now
the wheelchair is definitely just an
extension of my body because skaters
aren't always on their skateboards and
bikers aren't always on the bike but I'm
always on my chair so that gives me like
an unfair advantage to just practice
everywhere I go I feel like I'm lucky
that I always have my wheelchair with me
because I can just jump whenever I want
I was born with spina bifida I've had 21
surgeries throughout my life and I spent
a lot of time in the hospitals and yeah
it would be easy to just be bummed out
on that but I was for me I just found
the positive the wheelchairs just always
been this fun and it's wheels stuck to
your butt how's that not a great time in
2008 I got the Guinness world record for
the first backflip on a wheelchair now
is that a local competition here in
Vegas called am Jim that was a pretty
cool day one of my favorite tricks is
just simple hand flip because I always
loved watching skaters do it when I was
growing up and you know watching the
pros do it it's just something I wanted
to learn
I'm very blessed to be able to do what I
love and what I'm passionate about for a
living a lot of the time the wheelchair
comes with the stereotype of you can't
do this or whatever because it's a
medical device
I just always turn the wheelchair is a
great opportunity
[Music]